today we're going to be speaking with
sheila heen who's a harvard law school
professor founder of triad consulting
and also co-author of the new york times
bestsellers difficult conversations as
well as thanks for the feedback ashila
it's really great to have you on today
i'm delighted to be here
so i've every week i get questions from
people in my audience
um i have this
very big political disagreement with my
mom and i want to know how to handle it
or i have this difficult situation with
my co-workers politically and i want to
know how to handle it and
people ask me for advice and one of the
first things i say is well to figure out
the right path forward you kind of first
have to think about what you want the
outcome to be in other words in a
political disagreement with your mom
what's more important proving her wrong
or maintaining a relationship with your
mom for example depending on what what
you expect might happen so can you kind
of open up by giving us a basic
framework in terms of how to think
generally about some of these difficult
conversations that people sometimes have
absolutely and and david i think you're
right on the money meaning
i think one of the core questions is
what is my purpose
in having a conversation
because if my purpose is to prove her
wrong that that is not necessarily going
to change her mind you may have noticed
that true
right because it's totally clear to you
that you have proven her wrong
and yet
her views persist right um and so i
think that's part of the struggle which
is that um i actually think that there
are things that are hard about just
being in relationship with someone
who holds a view that you find
incredibly
disturbing upsetting
wrong-headed
um foolish uninformed should we keep
going
all those things yeah right right and
and and it's important also because
there's a range of
the example i give often is when people
say are you friends with like radical
right people for example i'll say listen
if someone thinks the tax rate should be
two points lower than i do
it's not a big deal it's just a
disagreement and we can kind of just
work through that it's not really going
to affect too many things about my
ability to relate to them if they
believe there's a secret cabal of jews
controlling every aspect of you know
right that's going to be a little bit
different in terms of our ability to
really relate to each other so it seems
like that context is important too
i think that that's exactly right and um
and so i think what we're talking about
are
views that feel like they hit at the
core of who we are yes
or that
suggest a threat to something that we
hold really
dear and so in this weird way there's
like an identity issue that comes with
like how could i
being who i am and what i care about and
um what i want people to
see about who i am and respect about who
i am how could i be
fill in the blank friends with
family with neighbors with co-workers
with this person
who
the at least the caricature of the view
that they hold in some way invalidates
dismisses or oppresses
something that really matters to me
about who i am and just that um
that identity
quake that comes with that question i
think is why we feel like we need to
have a conversation with them right and
what's what would thinking of techniques
you know sometimes it'll be like hey we
need to talk
or
you said something that really offended
me starting with how one felt there's
all these different tactics that that
are often mentioned
is there some universal best way to kind
of start some of these conversations or
does it really depend on who the person
is and what you're going to talk about
so i think that the the thing that it
depends most on is negotiating with
yourself about your purpose yeah
so for instance the the couple of
examples that you just gave if they just
said something or did something
that i want to raise well then there is
a purpose to the conversation and my
purpose would be
um i want to share with you
sort of what impact that had for me or
why i found it
upsetting or frustrating or um that
you're not really understanding
something that feels important to me for
you to understand right so my purpose is
actually to share something with you and
to feel heard well that's a purpose i
might be able to achieve
right right
um and if if i've got my purpose aligned
with something that feels realistic well
then i can start by just sharing that
purpose like hey whether or not you
agree i want you to understand why this
matters to me
that would be a great purpose and
depending on the relationship they may
or may not say like okay or they may
start explaining why you're wrong right
yeah you know when i spoke to um once i
i spoke to someone who has hired and
fired lots of people and i think this
will be kind of parallel to what we're
talking about and he said one of the
things he doesn't like which he did
early in his career when he would have
to fire someone is he would bring them
in and he would go listen um so i want
to talk because things haven't been
going so well lately and then the
employee might say they haven't i think
things have been going fine you're
already derailed right and you're kind
of trying to back up and so his his
thing was he would go
listen thanks for meeting with me
we're gonna have to let you go let me
explain to you why and then you're
putting out front that there's a
decision and there's a reality here and
now it's just a matter of kind of
thinking it through and talking it
through
is that where does that fit into the
techniques that you think can be useful
and is there something about that to
instead of listen um remember the other
day when we were talking about i was
like no i don't remember that just
saying
we we had a conversation that left me
feeling really upset with you and i want
to tell you what happened i want to is
there something about that as a
technique
totally totally so so one of the things
that you're describing is what we would
call a bad news conversation
like there's something uh that has been
decided or there's something that
matters to me
and the purpose of this conversation is
partly to let you know that yeah and if
the purpose of the conversation is to
let you know that then i need to put the
bad news up front and what's funny is
that if you ask people
if somebody has bad news for you or
needs to tell you something important
what what are your
requests of them yeah almost everybody
says like just tell me up front like
don't tiptoe into it or hide the ball or
make me guess
but then when we're on the other side of
the conversation we ease into it i've
watched someone try to fire someone by
asking them questions right
but don't you think you'd be better off
you know at a different organization and
it's not really it was a friend of
theirs right so we do it because
because of some of the identity stuff i
was talking about like i'm not the kind
of person who hurts people's feelings
i'm not the kind of person who treats
someone unfairly and and that's why
a lot of
getting ready to have a important
conversation
means negotiating with yourself like
well what's true you might hurt their
feelings yeah what's maybe you are
sensitive and and
maybe that's okay
and you need to let them know like look
this is just a topic on which i am
sensitive yeah we don't argue about
whether i'm normal sensitive or
oversensitive or you're insensitive
but if we're going to be in relationship
with each other this is where we're at
one of the other
situations that often comes up in the
political space and this is less about
people in my audience but more about
some of the people that i talk about
politicians or public figures
is allegations are often made against
people of all all different kinds and
then often there's like an instant
evaluation of how an individual reacts
when accused of something
and unfortunately what can be difficult
about it is
no matter how you react it's sort of
seen as though like of course that's
what being what's being said you know
and and whether the allegation is of
some kind of criminality we've seen this
in the context of the metoo movement you
know all sorts of allegations and if
people say i i absolutely didn't do that
the reaction can often be well that's
what everybody would say at least
initially right or most most people
would or
you kind of get the idea when there are
accusations being hurled
at you
what are some of the ways that are
better to respond maybe than what we
often see
well so um
i'll give an answer that i actually
learned from someone else so years ago
um
we were doing a program
in collaboration with another group and
and the other group included
people who did internal investigations
within the cia fbi et cetera and so what
they were teaching
was
um how to read signals that someone
might not be giving you the straight
story yep
so one of the things that i learned from
them is that one of the most common
red flags is what's called a protest
answer
so
if you accuse me of fill in the blank
rather than saying i absolutely did not
do that the person says
i can't even believe you would ask me
that
i can't even believe you would have the
nerve to etc etc so
what's interesting is not that if i'm a
truthful person and i didn't do what's
being accused that i wouldn't be
horrified that you're even asking or
suspecting me
um but what they would say is
if you are
innocent and telling the truth the truth
is your friend so the first thing you're
going to blurt out is the truth which is
like of course not
then you can add
i can't even believe you're asking me
that
so
so what's interesting is that you feel
if you're on the the being accused side
of it you feel both things and and it
can be tempting to think like i
shouldn't even have to say i didn't do
it
but do say that you didn't do it right
so like a reaction like
why would i do that that might be where
we say well you're not really denying it
i mean is that sort of the
non-responsive to the question yeah yeah
yeah the other the other um observation
that i learned from them was that
the biggest mistake we make if we
suspect something is going on is that we
don't ask the direct question right
right and they're like just ask the
direct question and get a direct answer
one way or another and it's not that
that proves anything
like you can't be a human lie detector
but it's at least a flag to say like uh
you might want to look into it a little
bit more
yeah in police interviewing techniques
which i've read about a bit one of the
things that's often said and you know
whether these things are always true or
mostly true i guess it depends depends
on circumstances but it's when you're
interviewing a truly innocent suspect
they will typically get really mad as
you continue to imply or suggest that
they did something they will genuinely
get mad that they are being accused of
this whereas guilty people
will do some of the things you're saying
or or kind of react in other ways
because it's genuinely infuriating to be
accused of something that you just you
just didn't do
yeah so so i think that's really
important which is it's not that you
don't feel the fury or the indignance
so so um being transparent about that
even as you are simultaneously being
transparent about what is not true
right let me also say david that this is
related to most difficult conversations
because we're often having the
conversation because something is wrong
yeah right something has gone wrong
somebody screwed something up somebody
did or said something that's a problem
um and the and blame is a feature of
most of those conversations if it's not
explicit it's implicit like you know we
need to talk about the fact that you
don't seem to know how to run zoom right
or use your microphone what is wrong
with you
and and
if the purpose of the conversation is
actually to fix the problem blame is
often not helpful
um because it's basically saying let's
talk about why you're the problem here
i'm the good guy and the victim and you
are the person who screwed it up and is
incompetent right it's not surprising
that not many people really want to be
part of that conversation like no thank
you i don't want to be in that play
with that being cast in that role so
so part of what we talk about if you're
actually trying to problem solve
is
um
shifting to talking about joint
contribution like what do we each do or
fail to do that got us where we're at
because that'll tell us what we need to
change if we're going to fix the problem
and not
have it reoccur right or be in the same
place
next week that's a little bit different
than the political situations that
you're talking about because they're not
actually trying to solve a problem no
it's usually about trying to to appear
as though you got one over on whoever
else you're speaking to or whatever the
case may be and that's really at cross
purposes with much of the productive
ways to have these conversations i mean
it's interesting because uh 80 of
political speech in the united states is
sort of structurally not even designed
to achieve anything
well what it's structurally designed to
achieve is not a conversation with the
other side right it's a conversation
with your face right yes so
so you are saying it because you think
it is going to persuade or influence
someone or something it's just not what
we're pretending it is across the aisle
or
across party lines
when it comes to when you're in the
middle of some kind of tense exchange
and this could be a debate i'm having on
my show with someone who disagrees with
me or someone talking to their mom about
whatever they said or you know whatever
the case may be oftentimes there's this
the the emotion kind of blocks your
ability to really think and then after
the fact you often say i knew so many
other things that i could have said but
i didn't say etc how how can you stay
kind of level-headed during these
exchanges
well so i would um
i would distinguish between
being emotional
and sharing emotion
because i would argue that you in those
exchanges you've actually got two layers
of things going on one is the debate
that we're trying to have or the issues
that we're trying to
what get one over on person yes you're
right or just better understand and so
part of the advice is shift your purpose
to can we understand why we see this
differently
if we can shift from proving that i'm
right to
it seems so obvious that i'm
right i'm just trying to understand why
we see it differently that's actually a
productive conversation
but you've got a second layer going on
under the surface which is the emotions
and relationship layer that that is all
about how i feel treated in this
exchange
yeah one tool along those lines that um
i've been told by a couple of different
people is it can be useful to say okay
let's say the topic is abortion uh i'm
pro-choice i'm talking to someone who's
against abortion
ask the other person why they believe
you are pro-choice to even see if they
understand even if they disagree with
your framework how you came to the
conclusion and that number one it's good
for everybody to have the knowledge but
just the
exercise of it might put the person in a
position that where they just by even
saying it they might at least be more
willing to understand your view if not
agree with it
i think that that's right and what it
highlights is that in any
really good conversation
um or attempt to influence by the way
um
you need two
things you need high quality
assertion like that you share your view
with
clarity and thoughtfulness and etc but
you also actually need high quality
empathy
that you are really listening generously
and deeply to each other to not to
because i think i'm going to agree with
you but because in order to understand
what might be persuasive to you i
actually have to understand what you
think and why you think it yes
and then i can say well so here's what
it feels like is left out of your view
or that i worry about that it sounds
like you're not so worried about so talk
to me about that so so when we talk
about high quality assertion it actually
has to be rooted in deep empathy and and
generous listening
so the move that you just suggested
um is a clever move although it's
basically backing the other person in
the corner to say be empathetic to me
first right and some people will take
that and say like yeah no i actually
think i can articulate your view and
that's helpful but if that doesn't work
it may be because you actually have to
do it first right that you need to say
so let me see if i can describe what
you're saying and why you
think what you think or feel the way
that you feel and then you can tell me
what's left out of that
and then
once they feel like you've you really
get it their view
then you're in a great position to
basically say like
okay so let me say a little bit about
why i see this differently and i i would
love it if you could
see if you can summarize it back to me
because this is just a complicated issue
right and that sense of reciprocity
which is one of the most robust findings
in the literature
like if you attack me i'm going to
attack you back
um but if if you're willing to listen to
me and consider
genuinely authentically why i think what
i think or feel how i feel well then
i almost feel an obligation to do the
same for you right so that would be like
with the abortion example it might be
hey listen
my my belief is you're against it
because you believe life starts at
conception so that any abortion is is
like a murder and
can you give me a sense of why you think
i am pro-choice and and so i'm kind of
doing it first in a sense
yes you can
um or
you might even tweet the question to say
can you give me a sense
and that's a genuine can you or do you
feel like you need more context from me
in order to understand that right
right because there's the
there's the general view of why people
are on each side of this issue but then
there's the u view like why do you david
care about this right
and and often around these really
important hot issues political issues
um one of the things that i hear is just
differences in what people worry most
about
so someone who is pro-life worries most
about the life of the
child
they would say child sure
and murder someone who is pro-choice
worries most about
other people
making choices for individuals and
what's interesting is that if you we
take a couple steps back politically
republicans
often worry most about
individual choice
and government interference in
individual choices which of course
in abortion that's flipped yes um
whereas democrats
often worry most about
the voices of those who are oppressing
not in the majority and equity right
or fairness and so
often one of the the ears i have on the
conversation is whatever it is we're
talking about what is it that each of us
is worried most about
and in some ways i don't have to worry
about what you're worried about because
i know that you'll take care of it right
if there wasn't anybody protecting
individual
autonomy or choice from government i
would have to worry about it but i can
rely on you guys to worry about it so so
i can worry about something else that
actually
matters to us as a society as well
super interesting we've been speaking
with harvard law school professor sheila
heen uh co-author of the new york times
bestsellers difficult conversations as
well as thanks for the feedback really
appreciate your time today thank you so
much
thank you